chaque petit pas chaque geste chaque
déplacement lui demande un effort
presque surhumain jean prat mensonge une
douleur quotidienne qui deviendra
insoutenable
nicole delà du souffre du syndrome
post-polio elle connaît son destin et il
est cruel j'ai pas par de mauvais mais
j'ai peur de l'agonie j'ai peur de 2
lundi min et de la perte totale
d'autonomie joue police elle ne sait pas
combien de temps il lui reste et pour la
première fois elle peut imaginer à quoi
s'attendre
si elle a recours à l'aide médicale à
mourir les directives sont prêtes
exclusivement destiné aux médecins
le guide de 70 pages couvre tous les
aspects d'un traitement qu'ils ne
connaissent pas mais qui sera disponible
dès le mois de décembre
c'est un gros morceau c'est clair ça on
ouvre une nouvelle porte une nouvelle
dimension une nouveau paradigme en
médecine qui ne s'est jamais fait au
québec
avant ça c'est clair en publiant chaque
guide mais on le publie
parce que on veut que ce soit bien fait
bien encadré le collège des médecins a
tout prévu
de concert avec l'ordre des infirmières
et celui des pharmaciens du québec tout
comme terre mortel sera administré par
intraveineuse en trois étapes sédation
coma arrêt cardio respiratoire
une technique plus humaine dit docteur
robert importée des pays-bas
parce que c'est elle qui permet le plus
possible d'avoir l'effet souhaité
rapidement mais le guide se veut surtout
un rappel pour tous les médecins des
règles à suivre
je le ferai jamais pour cette médecin
qui s'est toujours opposé à ce type
d'intervention
c'est l'équivalent de la peine de mort
ne me donnent des flexions savoir quel
maintenant dans le système de santé
on va causer la mort des patients pour
nicole gladu c'est tout le contraire
c'est un réconfort les consignes du
collège des médecins du québec confirme
que toutes les trousses d'injection
préparé par les pharmaciens permettront
aux patients de mourir avec leur médecin
dans le confort de leur maison
sécher - c'est et puis des amis
je voudrais mourir je voudrais mourir
comme comme j'ai vécu le plus possible
avec mon chat ça chercher pompiers qui
vous savez c'est évidemment dur tamara
d'envisager ce moment le final fatal
mais en même temps il fallait bien on
arrivé là préparer le terrain pour les
médecins mais parce que c'est dans trois
mois au mois de décembre que québécois
qu'un patient sera en droit de regarder
son médecin dans les yeux et de lui
demander est ce que vous pouvez
accélérer ma mort donc ce guide dont on
parlait est essentiel pour expliquer aux
médecins comment gérer ces demandes
parce que dès demain on y va en avoir on
sait pas combien
et elles sont difficiles donc qui sera
admissible
quels sont les critères qui sont
beaucoup plus restreints au québec
puisque prescrit la cour suprême pour le
reste du canada entre autres d'être en
soins de fin de vie donc fallait donner
un médecin qui jouent un rôle crucial
dans ce nouveau soin les outils pour
guider les patients dans system et
prendre les bonnes décisions
je parle de soins parce que ça devient
un soin à partir du mois de décembre
bon évidemment on l'entendait une
médecin l'a exposé son opposition
comparer ça un peu à la peine de mort
donc on craint des dérapages c'est clair
que c'est pas tout à fait réglé nous et
ce sont des craintes voudrait qu'ils
sont justifiées mais le collège des
médecins croient avoir retenu la formule
par injection qui est la plus vous
l'avez entendu humaines dans les
circonstances on va utiliser des
médicaments qui sont légaux qui sont en
pharmacie du cocktail qui seront
préparés par les pharmaciens mais au cas
par cas en vertu des conditions des
patients il n'y a pas de trousse
contrairement à ce que certaines
personnes pensent qu'ils seront
distribués très standard au médecin
voici l'euthanasie sur demande au
contraire le guide d
du collège des médecins se veut un outil
aussi peau au risque de banaliser une
pratique qui divise il vous l'avez
entendu encore beaucoup la commune la
communauté médicale
à trois mois de l'entrée en vigueur du
projet de loi il ya des médecins qui
pourront dire nous pourrons dire non et
ce biais de leur explique quoi faire si
par conscience il refuse de ministry ce
traitement
comment diriger le personnage de marc
merci beaucoup au revoir et ses
directives sur l'aide médicale à mourir
au québec frédéric elles sont inspirées
en fait de ce qui se fait un peu
ailleurs sauf qu'ici c'est le médecin
qui va jouer un rôle vraiment très
important oui effectivement donc une
inspiration assez libre des formules qui
existe à travers le monde
mais vous l'avez dit c'est important
aussi de faire la différence entre
suicide assisté et l'euthanasie et dans
ce cas ci on peut commencer par
l'euthanasie active c'est un peu ce qui
est proposé ici en fait au québec c'est
le médecin qui peut provoquer le décès
du patient ça c'est important
bien sûr le pays pionnier en la matière
ce sont les pays bas c'était le premier
pays à légaliser l'euthanasie active en
2001 s'est permis pour les gens qui sont
âgés de 12 ans et plus alors dans le cas
de mineurs évidemment ça prend bien sûr
le consentement des parents et il faut
prouver que la souffrance est
intolérable
les pays du benelux ont en fait les on
va dire les pionniers en la matière
puisque a suivi peu de temps après la
belgique
euthanasie le gall il égalisé pour les
adultes en 2002 et en 2014 année passée
ils ont étendu cela pour les enfants en
phase terminale et le luxembourg
également donc qui est assez similaire
oublie donc ça c'est pour l'euthanasie
active qui est évidemment très
différente du suicide assisté
oui le suicide assisté en fait c'est que
le médecin va montrer aux patients
encore lucide une méthode pour mettre
fin à ses jours donc le médecin il ne
prend pas la responsabilité de passer à
l'acte alors l'origan et et l'état
américain le premier à proposer cents à
ce sont pour les patients qui sont en
phase terminale par exemple qui n'aurait
plus que six mois à vivre
il faut également qu'il soit sain
d'esprit pour prendre cette décision
évidemment capital et surtout d'être en
mesure de passer à l'acte sans l'aide
médicale
ça c'est important l'état de washington
a suivi peu de temps après l'état du
vermont et l'état du montana également
et puis autre exemple de suicide assisté
qui est légalisée c'est en suisse où là
on parle d'auto délivrance au moyen
d'une substance létale à la il faut par
exemple il ya des preuves médicales qui
sont pas forcément nécessaire donc c'est
assez assez vaste comme interprétation
et le pays de la suisse est en fait le
seul qui permet aux étrangers de se
rendre en suisse pour aller mourir dans
une cliente dans une clinique
spécialisée
on l'a vu des cas des québécois par
exemple qu'il y aller ou d'autres
canadiens
mais quand ya pas de loi pour encadrer
l'euthanasie active ou le suicide
assisté
comment est-ce qu'on gère la volonté
d'un patient de vouloir mettre fin à sa
souffrance ou voulant mettre fin à ses
jours
payé plusieurs dispositions et céline en
fait on va parler là effectivement de
l'euthanasie passive à la salanque
lorsque le patient fait refuser
l'acharnement thérapeutique alors ya
plusieurs formules qui existent pour ya
des formules qu'on peut écrire dans le
testament
on peut par exemple refusé de prendre
tel ou tel médicament on peut stopper
également la machine ou encore on peut
prescrire une un médicament pour
soulager la douleur mais qui dans
certains cas va conduire à une mort
sereine c'est le cas notamment en france
dans certains pays comme le danemark à
novergie l'allemagne du loyer il ya des
formules totalement différentes qui
existent pour un problème qui est
vraiment un problème de société
aujourd'hui c'est sûr merci beaucoup
frédéric carré